et c'est toujours ça l'est toujours il
m'a un peu agacé donc non c'est vrai
à l'époque et maintenant non à l'époque
ah à l'époque
pas mon vomi comme on dit dans le jargon
les ex sont des ex quand on voit la
gueule du vomi
[Musique]
c'était une ex ou pas
du tout
mais Cindy vrai ou pas la vérité la
vérité dis la vérité mais regarde moi ce
que tu vraiment que je dise la vérité de
se retrouver parce que je suis quand
même contente d'être là Benjamin parce
que depuis toutes ces années je me suis
dit j'avais envie de revoir mon petit
Benji d'amour
[Musique]
il ne sait absolument rien passé de
secteur que tu as rien senti mais
non
Marie mon mari
Jean-Marie
à un moment donné donc voilà
tu participes à la saison 3 on l'a vu
ton portrait et comment qu'on puisse
dire c'est que tu as marqué le programme
il y a deux choses qu'on obtient
particulièrement chez toi la première
c'est que tu as un sacré caractère c'est
bon ça comme lancement et la seconde
c'est qu'on rigole pas avec le lait
d'ânesse
si je veux quelque chose je vais tout de
suite ou jamais j'avais trop envie
de me faire
j'en ai marre pourquoi
je suis capricieux
ah mais c'est bon ça m'énerve là le son
jeune des autres habitants me dérange
mais
comment
très très vite sur une plateforme aussi
Secret Story c'est vrai qu'il y avait
Cindy moi c'était ma préférée Cindy
c'est la seule vraiment que je retiens
de Secret Story est-ce qu'il y a des
séquences que tu regrettes non il y a
aucune séquence que je regrette je me
suis bien amusé dans ce jeu parce que
pour moi c'est un jeu et voilà je me
suis bien amusé j'ai adoré embêter mais
camarades voilà c'était cool j'ai jamais
pris ça au sérieux tout comme la
célébrité j'ai jamais pris ça au sérieux
donc voilà alors on va voir la première
saison de Secret Story ça date de 2007
et attention c'est encore une émission
présentée par Benjamin Castaldi et alors
c'était sur TF1 c'était pas sur M6
exactement c'était en deuxième partie de
soirée où ah non on a commencé
vous êtes parti en deuxième partie après
Koh-Lanta c'est ça l'enchaînement mais
pour répondre à la question est-ce que
les secrets vous y croyez moi quand on
m'a dit tu vas refaire le donc c'est
crête je pensais que c'était un twist
pour refaire le loft et je croyais pas
du tout au secret c'était un peu comme
vous et en fait les secrets
contrairement à ce que vous n'aimez pas
c'est quoi déjà c'est quoi le secret de
Cindy elle était pas en couple avec
quelqu'un ou avec
non mais je veux dire bon sexuel
Aurore aime beaucoup Cindy elle m'a
envoyé un texto elle m'a dit vraiment
c'était une question c'est marqué ta
nouvelle femme n'était pas encore ta
femme à l'époque non qui avait casté
Cindy mais c'est un peu les mêmes
joueurs de tempérament un peu hyper à
l'aise sur cette séquence sympa
je te sens pas comment
un peu calme-toi un peu je vois que
c'est pas bien si tu veux aller faire
pipi comment et moi tu peux y aller
alors on va revoir ça regardez c'était
la première de Secret Story c'était en
2007 et castaliste il y a 16 ans 16 ans
et vous n'avez pas changé Benjamin non
mais c'est vrai
que je vous dise vos yeux se sont
ouverts
[Applaudissements]
ça y est ça y est c'est ce soir c'est
maintenant le lancement de l'éventail
après toutes les plus forts rumeurs
entendues élus vous serez toute la
vérité rien que la vérité ce soir je
vous le jure vous connaîtrez enfin les
13 candidats SyFy cette garçons qui vont
vivre dans une maison de 900 m² et
surveiller 22h sur 24 par 50 caméras et
autant de micro
tous les sens on va faire pleurer Casta
sur ma vie
incroyables
c'est des grosses machines comme on dit
stressé ou pas énormément quoi
énormément moi je me foiré dans la dans
les 30 premières secondes je courais
après l'émission pendant deux heures
c'est horrible
il est très bon aussi
il est bon
oui
non non
il y a eu de nombreuses histoires
d'amour qui sont créées mon dérision
devait retenir qu'une c'était celle
d'Amélie et Sénart vous rappelez ou pas
ah ouais la quatrième saison regardez on
a même plus assister à leur demande en
mariage c'était fou ça dans Secret Story
je crois que il est temps pour moi que
je vienne un homme ton homme j'espère
[Musique]
est-ce que tu veux devenir ma fille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez alors ils sont vraiment mariés ou
pas
il y a un timing à respecter il y a un
emploi
sont plus réels que ça quoi
[Applaudissements]
il y avait beaucoup de Mythos parce que
Secret Story redevenir de revenir à ce
qu'il y avait beaucoup mythologie il
paraît qu'il y avait des gens vous
donniez les secrets genre toi voilà non
il y avait des secrets qui étaient
mécanisés c'est-à-dire c'est en fait il
y avait des quand on a un très bon
casting si on a quelqu'un qu'on veut
absolument avoir dans le programme et on
a pas de secret pas un gros secret on
lui inventé un secret
ton père a trois couilles on va inventé
un secret assez rare aussi
non mais on a inventé des secrets
mécanisés de rentrer avec avec son sa
sœur et tu manges quoi des mécaniques
mais des faux secret honnêtement je ne
crois pas voilà il était vrai ou il
était mécanisé
par Aurore
il a été demande
ah
mais non elle m'a testé oh là là
Benjamin j'avais pas fait la tête pour
ça
non mais attendez je vais maternelle
vous me faites venir on m'appeler à 17h
pour être là à 17h45 enfin je veux dire
si tout le monde se met à chialer à
moindre chose
[Applaudissements]
s'il te plaît parce que là tu vois
tu étais chez Jordan Deluxe toi tu sais
le gars avec le nœud papillon
alors déjà il y a un moment tu étais pas
en super bon terme avec Benjamin
ce qui a dit je suis Jordan de luxe
[Rires]
mais je sais pas sur tous les prime tous
les jours vous êtes pas un petit peu
fait des films
et en fait à la sortie de l'émission et
en fait moi je vous dis sincèrement ce
qui m'a énervé en fait c'est qu'en fait
tu pensais
je sais pas comment dire mais de me
mettre de considérer de façon inférieure
de de me rabaisser par rapport à sa
nanargue de l'époque il est même pas
resté d'ailleurs ça m'a un peu tu vois
avec cette époque de passer derrière tu
vois d'être la nana de cachette devant
me cacher pour pas nuire tu vois
l'intégrité de cette nana qui était
inexistante perdue dans le game ça m'a
vexé voilà pourquoi je rentre dans la
gueule tous les jours
c'est quoi le bail j'ai pas compris vous
avez pas compris
mais moi je pouvais pas aller dîner avec
un mec entre guillemets qui était enfin
en cachette enfin je veux dire moi je
suis pas une nana
charisme qui est quelqu'un quoi je veux
dire pourquoi pas enfin non d'ailleurs
c'est non d'office mais je veux dire là
je me sentais un peu vexé c'est que
rabaissé par quelqu'un qui est plus bas
que moi je ne peux pas sauf que moi je
ne compte sur des repas du tout
inférieur à qui que ce soit
demandé de dîner avec lui mais en secret
c'est ça
et donc tu vas tu lui as dit non en fait
moi j'étais vexé et après on a fait une
émission de télé un pilote avec Carole
Rousseau dont tu étais l'invité donc tu
es amnésique mais tu te souviens pas
l'émission
Carole Rousseau tu étais l'invité de
l'émission de Benjamin et moi sur le
plateau il avait été encore un peu
infecte supérieur au teint et rabaissant
oui franchement Benjamin tu es un peu
comme ça je suis désolé
mais moi je suis pas passé voilà c'est
dit c'est dit on en parle plus
mais rien du tout
un secret ah oui d'accord
vocalement
et vous vous êtes tartiné le feuillu
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas de secret veux savoir quel
secret à peux me donner pour que je
rentre dans l'émission forcément
un peu dragouillé pour le jeu quoi vous
l'aimez bien moi j'ai trouvé très belle
ça aurait été plus simple
[Rires]
non mais Cindy c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable parce que vous avez parlé
d'Aurore la femme de Benjamin chez
Jordan de luxe regardez
secret bisexuel c'était
vrai c'était vrai d'ailleurs c'est grâce
à la bah la dernière femme de Benjamin
Castaldi d'ailleurs que Orange ou tout à
fait que j'ai eu ce secret qui me va
très bien d'ailleurs est-ce que bon bah
c'est vrai qu'on s'est dragouiller
pendant le casting ça s'est vu sur les
caméras avec qui vous avez dragué
titiller
[Applaudissements]
les grosses poitrines
[Rires]
cette histoire ah oui c'est fou
j'imagine que c'était Aurore que
Benjamin tu avais invité à dîner que tu
avais dit non qui t'avait dragué
après de ne pas avoir une aventure avec
Benjamin Castaldi pour réussir il aurait
peut-être fallu que je sais pas je sois
plus conciliant
je suis tombé après
[Musique]